simple pong and Python 3 for beginners
part 1 let's take a look at what we're
gonna be building today
classic pong game so we've got a paddle
on the right we got a paddle on the left
and we've got a ball in the center okay
yeah the ball goes off the screen and
yeah opposite player gets a point then
the ball continues okay so that is what
we're gonna be working on so let's get
started today we're gonna be doing this
by using Python of course this is
written in Python 3 but it should work
in Python 2 as well I don't think
there's any Python 3 specific code in
this particular tutorial so we're gonna
be building this on top of the turtle
module I'm turtle module it was like
nice little module it lets you do some
basic graphics it's great for getting
started with games a lot of a lot of
tutorials use PI game which is amazing
it's got a lot of great features but for
beginners this is a lot simpler and it's
built-in you don't have to install it
like you do with Pi game so now that
I've got my turtle imported the module I
need to create a window so I'm gonna
call it WN you call twin WI N or
whatever you want to call it and but I
use W N and it's turtle dot screen
notice the S is capitalized it's very
important and I'm gonna give it a title
and I'm gonna call that pong buy at
Tokyo EdTech that's my twitter handle
you can follow me there you can
certainly subscribe here on YouTube and
and follow any new tutorials I have and
do feel free to you know leave comments
I do take keep a close eye on things and
if you have any trouble let me know and
I want to change the background color of
the window to black classic pong and I
want to change the size of the window
and I want the width to be 800 and I
want the height to be 600 pixels I'm
gonna do something called wind tracer
this one's a little bit hard to explain
but basically what that does is it
actually stops the window from updating
and so we have to manually
update it what this lets us do is
basically speed up our our games quite a
bit if we didn't do that things would
run much much slower so every game meat
needs something called a main game loop
and this is where basically all the meat
and potatoes of your your game goes to
so we're gonna make a loop while true
and I'm gonna put four spaces there you
can use tabs but spaces are recommended
but whatever you use make sure that you
are consistent you can't mix spaces and
tabs and then we do wind update and what
that does is every time the loop runs it
updates the screen okay just a quick
note this this program is written for
beginners so I'm not really using
object-oriented programming I'm not
really using classes except as it
relates to the turtle module this is
basically a really straightforward an
old-school style of programming
methodology so let's run that and see
how it goes and what we should have is
we have our title black background it is
800 wide by 600 tall zero zero is at the
center so plus 300 - 300 + 400 - 400
remember those numbers as they'll come
in handy in our next few tutorials
part two of simple pong in Python 3 for
beginners in this part of the tutorial
we're going to add our paddles to the
screen and we're going to add the ball
to the screen as well so let's get
started with that so basically what we
have in pong is we have pad I'm gonna
call it paddle a we have paddle B and we
have a ball
so those are the three items that we
need to add to the screen now as I
mentioned earlier in the previous video
we are using the turtle module to you
know add our graphics and to open our
windows and things like that it's very
very convenient it works great for basic
games a lot of people use Pi game which
is great but for simple games this is
probably an easier way to get started
so everything in our game needs a name
so I'm gonna call it paddle a very
original and it is actually going to be
a turtle what's known as a turtle object
so to do that it's turtle dot capital
turtle notice the capitalisation small t
because that is our module name capital
T because that is the class name now as
this tutorial is aimed at beginners I'm
not going to talk about classes I'm not
writing it object-oriented style I'm
just writing it in you know functional
style although there are some object
kind of patterns here you'll you'll see
but for beginners don't worry about that
stuff for now so then what I want to do
is paddle a I need to set the speed now
this is not the speed that the paddle
moves on the screen this is the speed of
animation this is just something we need
to do for the turtle module and what
this does is it sets the speed to the
maximum possible speed otherwise things
would be really slow we want to give our
paddle a shape and there are a few
built-in shapes and we're gonna use
square in this case okay there's Circle
Square
let's your Circle Square triangle a few
others we're gonna give our paddle a
color and or you can call it white
because that's what pong looks like and
we're going to
basically do something called pen.up
turtles by definition what they do is
they draw a line as they're moving we
don't need to draw a lines because
that's not what this program does so we
do the pet up and I want my paddle a to
start at minus 350
that's an x-coordinate and zero and the
vertically centered in the screen so in
our game zero zero is in the middle -
350 + 350 so I'm gonna go ahead and run
that and see what it looks like so far
okay so this is our left paddle now you
know you've played pong you've seen the
the demo from the first video clearly
it's not the right size so what we can
do in our program is this now just just
for your information by default that
shape is 20 pixels by 20 pixels so it's
20 pixels wide by 20 pixels high so what
we're gonna do is we're going to stretch
the shape so we use the shape size
method you can see I'm using Visual
Studio codes very good program even on a
Mac and it tells you you know what you
can do stretch with stretched lengths
etc etc so what I want to do is I want
to stretch the width by 5 so that's me 5
times 20 so that'll make it 100 tall and
then by 20 wide and stretch lame is
gonna be 1 we're gonna keep it at the
default so let's save that and run it ok
so you see now we've got a paddle over
here 20 pixels wide by 20 pixels high
okay now
so that's paddle a now I'm kind of lazy
guy so I'm just gonna copy this so what
I always recommend if something's
similar similar styles or similar you
know functions you know get it working
right once and copy it paste and just
make the necessary changes so now that
we've done that we just need to change
that to be
so if you keep consistent names it'll
really help your programming in this
case we want it to go on the right side
of the screen so that's gonna be plus
350 so I'm gonna run that and test it
and testing your program is very very
important at each stage a lot of
beginners I don't know why they insist
on typing the whole program in and then
trying to test it and you'll never be
able to figure out where the problems
are especially as a beginner unless you
do it step by step like this so we got
our left paddle we got our right paddle
so I just call it I said paddle a paddle
beam and then the last thing we need is
gonna be our ball so I'm gonna just go
ahead and copy this because it's
basically the same thing I don't need it
stretched I want to keep it the original
size and I want it to start in the
middle of the screen and I'm gonna call
it ball instead of paddle so you see
once if you do it like this method if
you get everything working correctly
there's no errors and you tested it then
you just copy and paste it really speeds
up your programming okay so I'm gonna
run that one more time okay you can see
we've got our left paddle paddle a our
right paddle paddle B and we've got our
ball which is starting in the center so
we're off to a good start
three let's take a look at what we have
so far okay so we've got our pong window
we've got our paddle a on the left
paddle B on the right and we've got our
ball in the middle so in this lesson
we're going to learn how to move the
paddles using the keyboard okay so what
we need to do is to basically we're
going to create some functions okay and
if you haven't ever used functions
before a function is basically kind of a
piece of a program that does a something
that's been defined for it so so in this
case we want to move paddle a up we want
to move paddle a down we move paddle
beat up when we've paddled B down so to
use functions you first need to define
your function and I'm going to call this
first function paddle a up okay you
recall in the last video I talked about
doing one function at a time or one
piece at a time getting that working
perfectly and then you can copy and just
make the necessary changes so that's
what we're gonna do here okay so paddle
a up so to move the paddle what I need
to do is I need to know the current y
coordinate so what I'm gonna do is gonna
say y equals paddle a dot y core okay
now this part here paddle a is the name
of the object we created here we called
it paddle a and the dot Y core method is
from the turtle module okay what that
does is it returns the y coordinate and
so we're just assign that value to a
variable called Y which makes sense okay
so we've defined the function using the
de f keyword you notice we have a I
guess it's the tab in this case well
it's it's a space we'll see I might get
an error there and that's maybe not a
second if we do and it's supposed to be
set to automatically change the spaces
but I think it's not set that way so
I'll leave it the way it is so then what
I want to do if I'm going to go up on
the screen it's this way so up so Y
increases as we go up it decreases as we
go down so I'm going to do is I'm going
to add 22 Y and this is the way you do
that you say Y plus
equals 20 so that will add 20 pixels to
the y-coordinate okay so now notice
we've just calculated the Y's so then
what we actually have to do is paddle a
set Y to the new Y so now having a
function doesn't actually do anything
until we call the function so the
function has just been defined but we're
not using it so what would you do is we
do something called a keyboard binding
okay so in the turtle module we need to
do W n so that was our window and listen
this tells it to listen for keyboard
input then we're going to use the on key
press method okay and watch what I do
here paddle a up W okay so let me
explain what that does so this line here
it tells the program to listen for
keyboard input this line here says when
the user presses W notice that the
lowercase W so if you have caps lock on
it won't work call the function paddle a
up okay here's our function paddle a up
paddle a up says get the y-coordinate
add 20 to the y-coordinate and then
actually set the y of the paddle to the
new y-coordinate okay so let's test that
and see what happens okay so I'm gonna
hit the W key okay so you can see how it
is moving up okay actually move it off
the screen okay so now that we've gotten
that working okay
what I can do is I can copy that okay
and I'm going to change this to paddle a
down so instead of adding 20 I'm going
to subtract 20 and then I need to do a
key binding for that as well so I'm
gonna copy and paste that so that's
gonna be paddle a
down and in this case I'm gonna use the
S key you can use whatever key you want
but I just chose nose cuz usually it's
WASD on the left and the arrow keys on
the right so again I've done one thing
I've changed it now I'm gonna test it
okay so W s okay so everything's working
exactly as expected okay so then what
I'm gonna do is now I've got both of
those working I'm gonna copy it and I'm
gonna do paddle be glad I'll be paddle B
so if you keep your naming consistent it
makes it very very easy to do what I'm
doing which is to be lazy and just use
copy and paste and then here now for
paddle B I'm gonna use the arrow keys
and then for the up arrow it's it's a
little bit different use up notice it's
capitalized and down is the down arrow
okay so yeah I made a couple changes I'm
gonna test my code okay so WS on the
left up and down on the right and voila
there you have it
hey stay tuned next next lesson we're
gonna get that ball moving
for moving the ball this is really kind
of the meat and the central kind of part
of the program this is where we actually
get the ball to move so we need to get
it to move we need to get it to bounce
off the top and the bottom and we need
to get it to bounce off of the paddles
and so I'm going to show you how that's
gonna work because we have our paddles
can move and but the ball does not yet
so let's say I get started with that and
so what I want to do is with the ball is
I want to separate the balls movement
into two parts and X movement and a Y
movement so what I'm going to call that
I'm gonna say ball dot DX D means Delta
or change you can even call it X speed
or whatever you want to but DX works
very very well now on my computer I've
found that too the number two works very
very well my computer at home actually
it was like 0.1 it's much much faster I
don't know quite know why seem I have to
play with the numbers here to get it you
know to where you feel the game should
be so so DX and dy equals two so what
that means is every time our ball moves
it moves by two pixels so since X is
positive it's going to move to the right
two and since Y is positive it's gonna
move up two so it'll be kind of moving
up and diagonally okay so to get that to
actually happen we have to go inside the
main game loop okay and in here I'm
gonna say move the ball so what we need
to do is ball dot set X and what we want
is the current x coordinate so I'm just
basically kind of combining what I did
up here into one line plus ball DX okay
so the ball starts at zero zero so zero
X so the first time through this loop
it's gonna go to then the next time to
the loop is gonna go to two two two two
so depending on your computer speed it
could just fly off the screen or it
could it can go a little bit slower so
again you'll have to play around
that a little bit so that I'm gonna say
ball dot set why and I basically the
same thing I can kind of copy and paste
it but I should have done and ball dot
DUI so I'm gonna say that and I'm gonna
test to see what happens you see some
red lines here I think there's gonna be
maybe we problem yeah so I'm gonna run
that and explain why it's not gonna work
okay so you see here I've got an error
and this is something again beginners I
don't know why do not want to read error
messages the error messages basically
tell you what's wrong
and so you see here's this tab error
inconsistent use of tabs and spaces okay
so I mention this in an earlier video so
here I used four spaces but here it's a
tab okay
you got to use the same thing each time
so I'm gonna go with four spaces that's
actually the preferred method now I can
set my editor upset when I hit a tab it
changes the four spaces automatically
but I'll do that another time okay so
I'm gonna run that and hopefully we'll
see the ball move okay so plus it's
going plus and right off the screen
alright which is what we expected okay
so that's that's good so now what we
need to do is we need to do some border
checking so what do we want to happen
when the ball hits the border okay so
since it's moving up into the right
we'll do the top border first we look at
the top border working then it's easy to
get the bottom border working so what we
have to do is we have to compare the
ball's y-coordinate okay so once it gets
to a certain point we want it to bounce
okay so if you recall earlier in the
program we set the height of the window
to be 600 so so that means that the top
the top y-coordinate is plus 300 the
bottom is minus 300 okay but the ball
itself is 20 to 20 high by 20 wide okay
so what we'll do then is we'll kind of
split the difference so we're gonna say
if the ball dot y core so if the current
coordinate is greater than 290 thank :
and I gotta use spaces it's telling me
2:34 if it's greater than 290 what we do
is we we set it back to 290 this avoids
certain types of problems and then what
we need to do is we say ball dot dy x
equals negative one okay and what that
does is it reverses the direction okay
so if dy is two so dy minus negative one
is negative two and that should reverse
the direction of the ball let's run that
okay so let's watch it and boom very
good that's exactly what we wanted to
happen
okay now since this is working correct
exactly as we want it I'm going to copy
and paste that and just make some
changes so on the other end it's less
than negative 290 we said it's a
negative 290 and that is that so let's
test that so test that we'll need to
start the ball off with a negative dy
for now again notice how I'm making a
change testing making a change testing
okay that's working that's about what we
wanted it was little bit off screen
better but we'll let that go so that's
the borders that's the top and bottom
borders okay now the next thing we need
to do is the left and right border so
this is where it gets not more tricky or
anything but you've got to think about
what we want to happen so in this case
because we're looking at left and right
okay we're not looking at the y
coordinate we're looking at the x
coordinate and now what we want to do is
if the x coordinate basically if it goes
off the the right side so if you
remember we said the width was 800 so
that means it's plus 400 on the Left
minus 400 on the right so let's say if
it's greater than
I'll say 290 sorry 390 so that tells us
it's basically it's going past the
paddle and it is off the screen okay
okay so if that's the case basically
we're gonna put the ball back to the
center zero and then what I can do is I
can maybe ball dot DX may have it
reverse direction okay so let's take a
look at that again I'm testing to make
sure it works and if it does that I can
copy and paste and do the other side
okay so we got an error okay so it says
we had a lot of weird stuff here that
was a really long one
and you say here you say this says line
87 so here's the line where it thinks
the error is and there's a lot of
different weird stuff but basically what
I forgot to do it was zero comma zero so
let's test that again so it should go
off the screen and I went back to the
center and reverse direction okay so we
know it works so let's copy that and
paste it and again we're gonna reverse
it so if it's less than negative 390 and
that's all we got to do
okay so again let's test it hopefully it
will come back okay so that's basically
that's exactly what we wanted to happen
okay
part five so in this lesson we're going
to learn how to get the ball to collide
with the paddles so let's see what we
have so far so we've got our ball it's
bouncing off the top of the screen
and it's at the edge of the screen it
goes back to the center which is what we
want so what we got to do is we got to
make it so that when it touches the
paddles it will reverse and how we're
gonna do that is basically what we're
going to do is we're comparing
y-coordinates of the paddle and the ball
so if we look at our code we put paddle
be at 350 so the x-coordinate of the
center is 350 and if you recall the
center it's that's right 20 pixels wide
by a hundred pixels tall so we need to
basically look at we need to make sure
that the ball is basically between here
and here and that it's basically between
here and here and if it is then we'll
call that a bounce okay so let me uh
kind of play the math a little bit on
that and give that a shot so it's let's
again as I mentioned before we're just
gonna try and get the right paddle
working and if we get the right paddle
working then it's easy to get the left
paddle working okay so I'm gonna say so
pedal and ball collisions okay so if the
ball dot XCore so if the balls
x-coordinate is greater than so we said
350 it's ten wide so it's greater than
say 340 and the ball well I should I
leave it at that
I'll leave it that and we'll come back
and fix it in a bit so that's one
condition and the ball's y-coordinate
is less than paddle be dot why core +50
here's a lot of stuff in here and
there's a lot of different things here
ball dot y core is greater than paddle B
dot y core minus 50 okay I'm glad that's
scrolling over so let me explain that
real quick
so if that's the case take notes Heather
if that is the case basically we just
want the DX same thing we did at the top
x equals one although this is X not Y
sorry negative one so if it's going this
way the DX is positive and a balance to
go back this way so what we want to see
is the ball x-coordinate greater than
340 that means the edges are basically
touching and is it between the top of
the paddle and the bottom of the paddle
actually there should be 50 it's
probably 40 because of the size of the
ball now let's let's play route that
let's test out see what happens
guess I want to run that oops okay so
did you see what happened there which is
not what we wanted okay see it bounced
there but watch what happens if I miss
it
see there's like a little bit of a
glitch there it's because even though
it's behind the x-coordinate is greater
than 340 and it's between here okay so
you see how that's kind of acting weird
so what you need to do is I'm gonna add
this condition and ball dot X core is
less than will say 350 so that gives it
basically to the middle of the paddle so
we'll say ball dot set X to 340 so that
moves it back to the left a little bit
and then it reverses the direction which
is what we wanted
okay so let me test that one more time
make sure it's working so it bounces
which is good
let's let it get past and see okay so
you see how it did not get stuck that
time so that's basically what we wanted
to happen so let's just test it one more
time yep so that's that's where we
wanted it okay so I'm just gonna
basically take this I'm gonna copy it
paste it and I'm just do the same thing
on the other side so minus 3 for t
greater than minus 350 and the top and
bottom doesn't matter but in this case
it's gonna be paddle a not paddle B that
would give you some definitely some
weird glitches and then say anything
we're gonna reverse the ball so let's
test it again okay so over here we're
using the up and down arrows they
bounced when we were here we're gonna
use the W and s Keys we test it okay so
something went wrong there hmm I know
what I did wrong so I had set X here to
340 it should be negative 340 so again
notice because I'm testing it you know
after every little bit of code I knew
that the problem had to be in here
somewhere
cuz that's the only thing I changed I
just got I can't emphasize that enough
cuz my students like I said they always
want to type the whole thing in and then
debug which is never a good idea okay so
let's test it one more time so you see
this process we're iterating we're
testing and just making sure everything
is working as expected before we move on
in park six we're gonna learn how to get
some scoring working so here's what we
have so far we've actually got a
functioning pong game the paddle on the
right is moving using the up and down
arrows the paddle on the left is moving
using W and s the ball is bouncing it's
doing everything it needs ooh
next we want to add a scoring system so
let's go and take a look at that so
basically what I do is we want to draw
the score on the screen and here's how
we're gonna do that in Python using the
turtle module so we gotta do is we
actually gonna create a pen okay I just
call it a pen but it's actually just a
turtle just like the ball like the
paddle but the the turtle module gives
these turtles objects a lot of different
abilities so I'm gonna make a pen and it
like the other is a turtle turtle again
I always spell that wrong and keep an
eye on the capitalization so small T for
the module name capital T for the class
name which we it's happening in the
background same thing as before so Penn
dot speed and again this is the
animation speed not the movement speed
it's not we're gonna move but we're
gonna give it a color penndot color the
shape doesn't matter because we're not
gonna see it if we want to print in
white on a screen like classic pong
style and penndot pan up this is because
we don't want to draw a line when the
pen moves every turtle actually starts
out at the dead center of the screen
then we move it somewhere if we don't do
pan up you'll see a line moving
I look between those two points and then
here we want to hide the turtle because
we don't need to see it now with the
ball and the paddle paddles we didn't
hide it because we want to see those on
the screen but with a pen we don't want
to see we just want to see the text
that's gonna write so pen go to and 0
comma I think 260 again I played around
with the numbers that's why I know 260
is a number I want if you remember again
the screen height is 600 so that means
it's 0 to 300 here so we want the score
to be right around this part of the
screen and then it gets pretty easy at
this point
as we use the right method so we want to
write and the right player a and now
when the game starts the score of course
is 0 2 spaces player B 0 comma and they
want to align equals Center because that
will Center the text force around that
point and then we want to choose a font
you know watch here I've got an extra
set of parentheses here okay don't
forget that and I want the font Courier
that's kind of old-school techy I choose
a font size of 24 and normal I think
normal I think you can choose bold and
italics and I represent sure on that one
so be very careful again we've got a set
of parentheses here and I got an extra
set of parentheses here for the font so
because there's three arguments we got
to send there okay so again now test
your code make sure this is working I'm
gonna run that okay so that's what we
wanted you see a Fred little space after
player B but yeah that's basically what
we wanted okay so that's how we get the
default score on the screen now what we
got to do is we need to keep track of
the score and so what I'm gonna do and
I'm gonna put this up here and score so
I need to create a couple variables I'm
going to call it score a and we start
the game it's way zero and score B is
gonna be zero now down down here okay so
we get a score when the ball goes off
the screen so here's the right size if
the ball goes off the right side thank
yourself who gets a score of course that
is gonna be player a so what I can do is
score a plus equals one i adds one two
player A's score and by the same token
on this on the other side
if the ball goes off the left side of
the screen player B gets that okay so
let's run that
oops okay so nothing we don't see any
change can you guess why okay
now if you said well we didn't update
the score on the screen you'd be a
hundred percent correct okay so what I'm
just gonna do is I'm gonna copy this
line here and I'm gonna put that into
here and you'll see what I got to do is
instead of the zeros this is just print
you know basic printing you know 101 so
we're not sure how to do that I do have
a video on that somewhere I'll try to
remember to link that below about how
printing works so we use the format
method on our string and we want score a
and score B okay so what that does is
put score a here and score be there so
I'm going to again make sure I'm using
spaces I'm gonna copy that cuz I'm
pretty sure this is correct so basically
every time I update the score I need to
update the actual printed score on the
screen or the Shone's displayed screw
score I should say so I'm gonna run that
now watch what happens here okay so you
can see it did update okay but clearly
something is wrong okay cuz basically
what it's doing is it's just printing on
top of itself okay so what we have to do
is before we do that call the right
method we say penndot clear now we'll
actually clear what's on the screen you
know it happens so fast that you don't
see it but it actually it does I'm just
gonna take my word for that one
again if you're using pygame or some
other you know framework or method you
might not have to do this type of steps
but for the turtle module this is what
you need to do okay so I'm gonna run
that and let's watch what happens
okay so player a just got a point player
B just got a point and so on and so
forth so yeah so basically we've got a
pretty well working game here again the
game never ends you just go until you
know until you give up and get bored
which is pretty easy with pong
I'm going to show you how to add a
little bit of sound to your game so just
basically you know what you need to do
to get started with that is you need to
have a sound you need to have a fast
ound file and what i've done is i have
downloaded this file from I forgot the
site now but it is balance dot wave and
it's like kind of a classic old-school
bouncing sound you'll hear it in a
minute now
Python is generally pretty
cross-platform basically everything
we've done so far it doesn't matter
which operating system you're using
Linux Mac or Windows everything that
works the same sound is one of those
things where it doesn't work the same so
right now I'm on a Mac and I'm going to
show you how to do it on a Mac and then
I'll talk about how you would do it then
on Linux or Windows ok so that's it's a
bit different okay so the first thing I
got to point out is that the sound that
I found bounce dot wave and WAV files
generally are more compatible across
platforms of compatibility is in the
exact same folder as my Python file so
right now I'm on pong 7 and pong sevens
in there so they are in the same folder
that's that's a really important point
now that you can even work around that
if you know what you're doing but for
beginners this is probably the easiest
way to do things and so basically it's
really simple when do I want to play a
sound and so I'm gonna play a sound when
I having to put it when I when the ball
either touches one of the borders or
bounces off of the paddle okay so in Mac
okay so I'm gonna use something called
the OS module and what that lets us do
is basically interact with the operating
system through text commands and so I've
imported OS so I can use that module and
then down here so what I can do is I can
say OS that system that will do a system
function call for us now on Mac it's a
play
bounce MP bounce dot wav so this is it
this will play the sound when it hits
the border now there's there's a problem
here and I'm going to show you that in a
second but again let's test it see what
happens
oops went the wrong way the wait till I
get to the top I'll turn my volume up
oops
sorry my bad a play is for Linux AF play
is for Mac let's try that again got that
backwards I had a 50-50 chance and I
blew it
ok let's listen now did you notice that
everything stopped while that sound
played so watch it again okay that is
not what we want to happen okay so to
get around that at the end of this
command we need to add an ampersand
that's the end symbol okay so yeah let's
test it
and I'll watch it will not delay okay so
a little bit it's a little bit off but
that's you know neither here nor there I
suppose we want to deal with that okay I
think actually what I would probably do
is edit this this wave sound there's
probably a little bit of a blank space
at the beginning of it so that's that's
it on Mac okay so let me copy that and
let's say we want to play it when it
bounces at the top bottom and when it
touches the paddles so we just need to
put oops I'm gonna do that okay so let's
test it so again I got it working once
now I just copy and paste so I should
bounce here just that I'm terrible at
pong apparently okay now you can choose
different sounds you have one sound for
when it bounces off the walls one cell
for when it bounces off the paddle etc
etc okay now if you are a Linux user the
system is very very similar
instead of AF play it's a play and
that's all you have to change okay now
for our windows it's a little bit
different now I can't test it for you
but I can explain how it works and I do
have a video that explains this and I'll
try to remember to link that down below
and basically in Windows instead of
importing OS you import wind sound which
is a little module that only exists on
Windows and then when you want to play
your sound instead of this OS dot system
stuff you would type win sound dot play
sound again pay attention to the
capitalization okay
small W capital P capital S then in
parentheses so you don't need the
ampersand here but you do need a comma
and a wind sound dot snd async so what
that does is that same thing as adding
the ampersand that'll stop you have it's
asynchronous
it'll play the sound in the background
if it's not a synchronous program will
stop again I can't show this to you
because this is Mac but that should
should do it so I'm gonna undo that and
get back to my sister oops somebody
wanted to I keep going yeah a play and
it's AF play let's leave that I'm gonna
test it one more time and that is our
bond program